foreign
yes I I've got almost a hundred thousand
dollars in my checking account uh at the
bank and I'm kind of I'm 60 or 76 years
old and I'm getting kind of nervous uh
sure how I've been looking at uh
gold and silver and stuff you know what
would you do with that money instead of
having it in the bank all that money
tell us what you're most nervous about
foreign
[Music]
I don't trust the government come on all
right welcome to the club
welcome to the club you and I can wear
the same hat
um so so play that out a little bit
um I don't trust the government either
but what what are you what is a a really
uh serious concern and fear that's
making you call us right now or you
think they're going to raid your bank
account what's going on here right yes
what would cause them to do that
uh because the way he's spending money
he's going to figure he needs some more
money okay all right okay all right I
see what you're saying Rachel what's
what are some options here so Linda I
love your line of thought and everyone
that knows a little bit of me I just
love a good conspiracy theory so I've
been down every Rabbit Hole you can
imagine
um but I think though Linda
um the truth is if that really did
happen I think a war would break out
if the government came in and started
taking people's money yeah from their
personal savings and checking account
we have other problem like it would it
just I just don't I genuinely
don't see that happening personally yeah
could I mean could you make a case for
it Linda uh sure it it could they can
drum up any kind of reasons I mean they
really could do just about anything they
wanted to do do I think that's gonna
happen yeah but Linda I don't think you
need to be worried about that right now
I would and I don't want you to be
investing in gold or silver no yeah
Commodities like that Lindsay they don't
they don't hold their value and do you
have any any Investments Linda that you
are living off of is it like from
previous retirement or anything or is it
just that money in the bank that is is
your nest egg no I I make about eight
thousand dollars a month income comps I
sold some properties okay yeah so I got
lots of income yeah but it's just been
nervous about uh you know I even thought
about putting it in in a safe you know
but I don't think that's right you see
you know yeah that's the last thing you
want is everybody in your community
seeing a big old truck come in with a
safe hey what's going on over at Linda's
house right yeah right do you have a
financial advisor
no I don't I really recommend
um you trusted us enough to call the
show today I I really recommend that you
get on our website ramseysolutions.com
and I would love for you to to seek out
on our website smart investor Pros these
are men and women that we vetted out
because of their values they understand
how Dave for three decades has treated
people and and they're going to coach
you and and you can interview them you
don't have to choose the first one that
you meet with meet with several in your
area but just really explain some of
your worries and uh your your concerns
and some ways to protect yourself and I
think that it will just show you several
things number one your options
um and and and and then number two just
what would have to happen for those
fears of yours to come true what your
protections are what you can do how you
can diversify some of that money because
you've got really good income coming in
yeah I would even talk to them about
offshore accounts and things of that
nature I'm no expert on that but the
bottom line is they know about
investment opportunities things like
where you can protect your money you
know from things like this and you
invest your money you know I'm just
saying I'd look into it I'm not an
expert I talk to one of our smart master
Pros about it Rachel's freaking out
right now no it's a way to protect your
money I mean it's it's people do this
they invest it and it's it's it is a
thing so yeah and I thought you know
I'm getting to the point where I I worry
uh
I'm worried about my money you know yeah
uh and I'm a widow so I I got no husband
to advise me you know well let me let me
tell you this too Linda that um you know
we say around here a lot that there's
been a lot of fear in our economy and in
our culture over the past few years I
feel like it's just risen uh for
multiple reasons and we just never make
decisions out of fear usually when
decisions are made completely out of
fear it's in the short term
um to rest aside that fear but then long
term when you look out you know three
four five years it's not always
um the best decision but you made it
kind of in a vacuum out of fear so I
really
um want to just give you peace that you
know if something we're and we're in
this industry all the time so we're
talking to people we're seeing things
going on we're reading the news all of
it and if something fell off like we
would we would definitely be talking and
again I think it I think things can be
off for sure and some people think
they're way off more than others but
overall though I I just don't I don't
see that happening in the near future at
all
um personally so I have money in in the
banking system uh actually most of our
money is or Investments and so yeah it's
something that um that we're doing so
that's how we give a lot of this advice
as well as things that we're doing but
you could look Linda
um how much did you say is in the bank
right now
that's it well it's a little over uh a
hundred thousand okay yeah and and this
may I don't know I'm just thinking of
way to diversify I think Ken's saying to
meet with a investment professional is
like is a great
um Step
but it could be you know if you
I don't know I don't know if I'd fool
with it I was gonna say you know buy you
know a little bit of real estate like a
condo or something and having money and
I just got rid of him
driving me crazy
I was cautious you would say it I should
have said it I know I want you to know
as soon as she said that I rolled my
arms I I don't know why Rachel told you
that no you know what listen a smart
investor Pro is going to give you
honestly some really great advice there
are other investment opportunities for
you where you are protected from the
federal government and again they can
help you on that so you've got some
options smart does Smart investors smart
yeah hang on the line we're gonna make
sure that we get you right to the spot
on our website smart vesterpro is the
section on the website but our team uh
is gonna get you right there and I want
you to interview several people ask all
the questions Linda that you want to ask
because you feel comfortable there's
even Investments to to go into Linda
that even have like a moral scape that
it's like okay if you are a Evangelical
believer here's funds around that like
you could even look specifically into
different things for sure
um and by the way to come back to what
I'm saying the reason people use
offshore accounts is to protect their
money from their government so foreign
countries if you feel it sounds like it
sounds like a movie there was a movie oh
you just put your money in another
country's Bank it was a movie with
Cameron Diaz and he had like all of his
money I think illegally in his offshore
no I was not suggesting illegal that the
money itself would be illegally gotten
but the that is a viable thing to
protect yourself from your government
yeah because people do it maybe we
should be doing it all right are you
doing it no because I'm okay I'm not
worried about it it's gonna be all right
you know I think you know it's gonna be
okay Linda I promise